vous voulez revenir sur la grande cause
du quinquennat et parfois ce décalage
entre la société civile qui avance vite
sur ce sujet là qui a des attentes
importantes et puis la loi et la classe
politique surtout en effet bonsoir
madame la Présidente merci de me donner
cette occasion de vous poser cette
question qui est que pouvez-vous faire
en tant que président de l'Assemblée
nationale pour faire en sorte que les
promesses qui ont été prises par le
Président de la République et votre
majorité souhaitent effectivement mis en
oeuvre je m'explique nous sommes
aujourd'hui le
lequel jour sommes-nous le 30 novembre
2022 et depuis le 1er janvier il y a
déjà eu 124 féminicides depuis le début
du 1er quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron en
2017 les féminicides n'ont pas reculé
les agressions sexuelles n'ont pas
reculé les moyens des associations ont
certes légèrement augmenté néanmoins le
budget du ministère de l'Égalité pour
les femmes pour l'égalité fameux pardon
reste l'un des plus petits budgets de
l'État que faire effectivement entre ces
annonces qui semblent relever d'une
certaine forme de communication
politique qui sont parfois et c'est le
sentiment des associations sur le
terrain qui ont le sentiment que c'est
soupoudrer de petites mesures mais qu'il
n'y a pas de véritable réforme
structurelles pour lutter le milliard le
fameux milliard que réclame les
associations qui est passé à 2 milliards
désormais qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on
peut attendre réellement de ce
quinquennat dans la matière je partage
pas du tout votre analyse nous avons ce
n'est pas mon analyse c'est l'analyse
des associations sur le terrain alors
un gros décalage entre les annonces et
les moyens je ne partage pas et moi qui
vais beaucoup sur le terrain là je
reviens de Lille où j'ai passé une
journée avec la députée violette
spielbou justement consacré à la lutte
des violences faites aux femmes et j'ai
échangé longuement avec plusieurs
associations et plusieurs femmes
victimes de violences et ce n'est pas ce
qu'elles m'ont dit donc peut-être que
certaines associations pensent que vous
dites mais ça n'est pas la totalité de
ces associations
et bien les chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes
nous avons voté quatre textes pendant la
précédente mandature plus un texte sur
l'égalité
des des hommes et des femmes dans le
monde
vous avez raison il y a la libération de
la parole mais nous avons fait nos
besoins du gouverne nous avons fait mais
nous avons
formé des policiers pour recueillir
cette parole pour recueillir cette
parole c'est très important nous avons
signé des conventions avec les hôpitaux
pour pouvoir justement lorsque les
femmes se rendent dans des hôpitaux que
la le dépôt de plainte que la
recueille des des éléments permettant de
matérialiser l'infraction soit facilité
nous avons accéléré profondément la
prise en charge judiciaire avec la
réduction considérable des délais de
l'ordonnance de protection qui avant
mettaient à peu près 40 jours avant
d'être prononcé qui maintenant doit être
renoncé dans un délai maximum de six
jours nous avons doté toute la
juridictions de bracelets anti
rapprochement de téléphone
les TGD ce qu'on appelle les TGD et les
bars ont effectivement été augmentés
mais les moyens pour accompagner les
personnes bénéficiaires n'ont pas été
augmentées donc aujourd'hui les
associations se retrouvent à devoir
gérer ces fameux dispositifs sont les
moyens nécessaires gravement grave
danger et aussi
c'est quand même mais vous-même que nous
en sommes d'accord nous avons fait des
choses nous n'avons pas rien sur ce que
je veux dire c'est ce qui serait pas
temps de passer une étape supérieure moi
je crois que l'exemple espagnol par
exemple
spécial formés avec des juges dédiés et
moi c'est mission des violences
dédiés et formés à ces questions partout
sur le territoire et moi je considère
que avoir des réussi peut-être là où on
a encore du mal mais non quasiment
éradiquer on a fait des progrès mais
majeurs il y a encore beaucoup à faire
et c'est un combat qui doit tous nous
occuper évidemment le gouvernement le
Parlement les associations qui un boulot
extraordinaire en la matière mais parce
que il y a cette proximité cette
humanité c'est bien moi j'ai fait partie
du monde associatif je sais ce qu'elles
apportent sur ces causes là sur ces
combats là mais c'est un combat qui doit
tous nous préoccuper bien évidemment les
élus locaux moi j'ai visité une un
bâtiment qui allait bientôt dans
quelques mois accueillir plus de 45
femmes victimes de violence donc et
c'est une volonté du maire de la
préfecture de l'État qui financement
tous les acteurs sont mobilisés et le
fait de faire une grande cause du
quinquennat permet c'est la validation
et va plus vite que la loi pour terminer
madame la Présidente peut-être cette
question se pose aussi à l'Assemblée
nationale on a parlé du MiTo en
politique est-ce qu'il faut créer
davantage de dispositifs les
collaborateurs les députés il y a eu
évidemment des des cas des cas
d'informations judiciaire et même des
condamnations parmi la représentation
nationale il faut faire davantage ce qui
est important c'est que avec me tool la
parole s'est libérée il faut une fois
que cette parole est libérée que l'on
puisse la recueillir l'écouter partout
et donc elle a semblé nationale nous
avons cette cellule anti-harcèlement qui
existe qui recueille les témoignages et
qui peut effectivement faire des
articles 40 pour porter plainte c'est
fondamental il faut continuer et il faut
toujours encourager les femmes les
victimes à parler merci beaucoup merci
infiniment il y a LeBron Pivet d'être
venu en direct une heure de direct sur
la chaîne parlementaire ça sera pour une
présidente de l'Assemblée vous avez un
modèle parmi vos prédécesseurs
d'ailleurs pour terminer d'un mot un
grand président qui vous inspire une
présidente Philippe Seguin Philippe
Seguin et ben voilà c'est dit
il portait vraiment comme tous les
autres mais peut-être lui a incarné très
fort l'amour de l'institution merci
beaucoup vous merci à vous de pire en
Rita voyou et à chambre dans cette
émission très belle soirée sur SCPI à
demain
[Musique]